yeah I think experiences have definitely
impacted me again I've been doing
recruitment eight or nine years now
right so I've I've kind of been through
a lot and I think the pain of of sort of
you know seeing your book fall down to
like over half overnight and you know
having to build that money back up again
and build out that contract book I think
that's that is a big pain for me and
the fault of my book like going
overnight is a killer and I think if you
remind yourself of that yeah reminding
myself of you know the graph that put
no one likes to graph right you know
everyone would love to be lazy no one
likes to work hard and graft and I think
knowing that going back to that a
careful graph I've got to hit the phones
and I think that's again that's what's
like I don't want to be doing that I'm
in a good place right now I don't want
to be doing the extra hard hours I like
to be working 14-hour days every week
and starting over again I think that has
pushed me on to to be on top of things
but I think for me as well is I've
always you know I've always ripped
things down you know all my important
topics I write it down and if it takes
me a month two months three months to
complete it so what as long as I'm
chasing every day and then it's there
and I'm noting it down that has helped
me as well stand on top of things and
and not being complacent you know even
it's like catch up with John catch up
with him whatever it is it's just small
things like that to to make sure that
you aren't being lazy and being on on
the back foot that's that the key things
I sort of do really the recruitment
mentors podcast is proudly sponsored by
vincere and the award-winning Source
breaker